you did something with your show that
man this really stuns me you make the
pilot for Angie Tribeca yes and you cast
your father the famous Quincy Jones as
your father in the show
yeah then after the pilot you recast him
and give the part to Ernie Hudson okay
that is cold let me let me just let me
clarify flyers Quincy Chaplin
you're at Jones okay the truth is that
that part became kind of more than just
a cameo you know and I'm not saying my
dad is a great actor he's actually
currently in that Adam Sandler movie on
Netflix and he does really funny in it
sandy Wexler yes sandy Wexler yeah but
and so yo we're all in it anyway he's a
great actor but we just you know we just
wanted to give somebody else a shot yeah
he's a pretty illustrious career yeah
your dad doesn't it's like at this point
he has pretty much accomplished
everything you can possibly accomplish
in the realm of show business I'm trying
to keep him humble yeah I mean this it
feels like I can't think of anybody who
would know more famous people than your
father no I think he's number one I
think he's never he knows in terms of
knowing absolutely everyone is he did he
named Rob like crazy he you know what he
does but it's okay like he's allowed
he's 84 he's had the pretty much the
best career you could possibly have a
position and he does often tell me like
he gives me a rundown of wherever he is
at any given moment it could be Dubai it
could be China like it could be his
living room but it just gives me like a
list of people who are there at that
moment yeah yeah it's just like you know
could be anybody from like you know :
Powell to like the cast of a Broadway
musical or you know I don't know just
just anybody that's important in any
sphere of life like you know I I'm kind
of like that but it's not the same
caliber you know right like what what's
your I'm like I'm here I'm hanging with
remember the Duggars the people to have
those babies
every single November two of them are
here two of them are here Wow and
there's the guy that gets a lot of work
and FedEx commercial is easier to great
can I not come over
you